ein
[Musik]
karel gott war die goldene stimme aus
der goldenen stadt prag seine
romantische tenorstimme mit dem
charmanten akzent begleitete
generationen mit dem titelsong zu die
biene maja landete er einen welthit
einmal hören und schon ging ich zum
mikrofon
nach 20 minuten war die aufnahme fertig
wer hätte das damals gedacht 19 77 das
ist so eine adwords 1939 wollte er als
carlotta in pilzen geboren zog mit den
eltern später nach prag
er wollte kunst studieren doch die
akademie lehnte ihn mit diesem bild ab
er wurde wie es der vater wollte dann
elektromechaniker tingelte aber weiter
durch tanzcafés wo man ihn schließlich
entdeckte ab da studierte er gesang am
konservatorium in seiner heimat wurde er
als sänger zum idol der jugend in den
sechzigern feierte er trotz des eisernen
vorhangs dann auch in deutschland
erfolge eine westliche plattenfirma
hatte ihn denn frank sinatra des ostens
unter vertrag genommen
der osten ließ es zu da er mit seinem
erfolg zum wichtigsten devisenbringer
wurde
karel gott schaffte es sogar bis nach
las vegas wo er als der erste singende
kommunist vermarktet wurde
er verstand es sich mit den politischen
welten zwischen denen er pendelte zu
arrangieren
in deutschland prägte er mit seinen
sehnsuchtsvollen liedern die
fernsehabende
[Applaus]
obwohl er nach wie vor der malerei nach
ging gab es nur eine ganz große liebe
wirklich sehr oft verliebt war trotzdem
eine einzige richtige feste lebens
bindung ist die bühne
er war ein frauenliebling der allerdings
erst mit 68 heiratete und noch zwei mal
vater wurde zwei erwachsene töchter
stammen aus früheren beziehungen seine
kinder waren sein ein und alles und die
bühne bis zum schluss seine welt
[Musik]
die leute spüren dass ich sie mag ich
liebe mein publikum uns das ist nicht
falsch und das führen sie und das werden
die menschen von karel gott immer in
erinnerung behalten
[Musik]